Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. And today, Tom, we are going to be talking about a country that I've actually seen play at the World Cup, which is Tunisia, a country with a... Have you? I have in... I know you don't want to talk about football too much, but I saw them play against Colombia in 1998 in the French World Cup.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。汤姆，今天我们要聊一个我实际上在世界杯上亲眼看其踢过球的国家，那就是突尼斯，这个国家有着…… 你见过？我见……我知道你不想过多谈论足球，但我在 1998 年的法国世界杯上看过他们对阵哥伦比亚的比赛。
How did they do? Colombia won 1-0. That's a shame. Tunisia generally, well, I mean, generally better known, it's not as well known for football as it was for Barbary Pirates. Child Sacrifice. Well, come to Child Sacrifice. It was the breadbasket of the Roman Empire.
他们踢得怎么样？哥伦比亚 1 比 0 赢了。真遗憾。突尼斯通常，嗯，我是说，人们通常更了解它的不是足球，而是巴巴里海盗。儿童献祭。好吧，说到儿童献祭。它曾是罗马帝国的粮仓。
And before that, it was the centre of the great city of Carthage, Rome's deadly rival. And which, according to legend, was founded by a woman called Dido. And so I thought that today's episode, in honor of Tunisia, we would go right back to the beginnings and look at Dido, who is the founder of Carthage. And she's a legendary figure, but her best known incarnation is as the great tragic heroine of the Roman poet Virgil's epic, the Aeneid. And the Aeneid, it's an epic that tells the story of the founding of Rome, how Rome comes to be founded by a band of exiles from Troy. And these Trojans are led by Aeneas, who is the son of Venus. He has escaped from Troy. He's come with a fleet of ships.
在此之前，它是伟大城市迦太基的中心，也是罗马死敌。根据传说，迦太基是由一位名叫狄多（Dido）的女性建立的。因此我想，今天的节目为了致敬突尼斯，我们将追溯到它的起源，来看看迦太基的建立者狄多。她是一个传奇人物，但她最广为人知的化身是罗马诗人维吉尔的史诗《埃涅阿斯纪》中的伟大悲剧女主角。《埃涅阿斯纪》这部史诗讲述了罗马建城的历史，讲述了罗马是如何由一群来自特洛伊的流亡者建立起来的。这些特洛伊人由维纳斯的儿子埃涅阿斯率领。他从特洛伊逃了出来，率领着一支船队来到这里。
And the epic opens with them being shipwrecked off the coast of what is now Tunisia. And they go wandering off, trying to find someone to help them. And they discover this great city being built. It's in the process of being constructed. And Virgil gives this great city being built. It's in the process of being constructed. And Virgil gives this great phrase. It's one of the great Latin tags, Dux Femina Facti. A woman was the leader of the enterprise. And this woman is the Queen Dido, who has come from the Phoenician city of Tyre. So Phoenicia is now Lebanon. And the leader of this expedition is Dido, who is a queen from the Phoenician city of Tyre. So Phoenicia is now Lebanon. And the leader of this expedition is Dido, who is a queen
史诗开篇便是他们在现今突尼斯海岸附近遭遇海难。他们四处游荡，试图寻找救援。然后他们发现这座正在建造中的伟大城市。它正处于建设过程中。维吉尔为这座正在建造的伟大城市留下了一句名言。这是拉丁语名言之一：Dux Femina Facti。一位女性成为了这项伟业的领袖。这位女性就是狄多女王，她来自腓尼基城市推罗。所以腓尼基就是现在的黎巴嫩。这次远征的领袖是狄多，她是一位来自腓尼基城市推罗的女王。腓尼基现在是黎巴嫩。这次远征的领袖是狄多，她是一位女王。
from the Phoenician city of Tyre. Phoenicia is current day Lebanon. She's gone into exile. And she's arrived at this promontory sticking out into the sea in North Africa. And she has been given land to construct the city. And she's very keen on Aeneas. She plays host to him. Aeneas tells her the story of the Trojan War, the Trojan horse, all that kind of stuff. Yeah. That's where that tradition comes from. And they fall in love.
来自腓尼基城市推罗。腓尼基就是今天的黎巴嫩。她陷入流亡，抵达了北非伸入海中的这个岬角。她得到了建造这座城市的土地。她对埃涅阿斯非常倾心。她盛情款待了他。埃涅阿斯向她讲述了特洛伊战争的故事、特洛伊木马以及诸如此类的事情。是的。这个传说就是这么来的。他们坠入爱河。
Oh, it's a lovely story. It is a lovely story, but it doesn't end well because they go off hunting. There's a thunderstorm. They end up in a cave and whoosh uh it it's all kinds of shenanigans that are happening there now juno the queen of the gods is very happy about this because she wants to frustrate the destiny of aeneas to found this city that in turn will lead to the founding of rome And Venus, who is Aeneas' mother, is very keen
哦，这是一个动人的故事。这确实是一个动人的故事，但结局并不美好，因为他们去打猎。遇到了一场雷雨。他们最后进了一个山洞，然后呼——呃，那里发生各种各样的恶作剧。现在，众神之后朱诺对此非常高兴，因为她想破坏埃涅阿斯建立这座城市的命运，而这座城市反过来又将导致罗马的建城。而埃涅阿斯的母亲维纳斯则非常热心。
because she wants to see her boy settle down with a nice girl. So she's very keen. But Jupiter, the king of the gods, bury cross because it is Aeneas' destiny to go off and do all the founding that will culminate in the founding of Rome. So if he's hanging out in a cave with Dido, it's not going to happen.
因为她想看到自己的儿子和一个好姑娘安定下来。所以她非常热心。但众神之王朱比特却怒火中烧，因为埃涅阿斯的命运是去远行并完成所有奠基大业，这些大业最终将促成罗马的建城。所以如果他和狄多在一个山洞里厮混，这一切就不会发生了。
Getting up to no good. So he's frustrating destiny. Yeah, exactly. So he sends down Mercury and Mercury says, what are you up to, to Aeneas? And he comes up with another cracking Latin tag, varium et mutabile semper femina, fickle and ever changing is woman, which is absolute classic of mansplaining, of course. And Mercury would be in deep trouble now. Yeah, he would. Because actually, the person who's being fickle is Aeneas,
不务正业。所以他破坏了命运。是的，完全如此。于是他派下了墨丘利，墨丘利对埃涅阿斯说，你在搞什么鬼？他想出了另一句精彩的拉丁语名言：varium et mutabile semper femina（女人总是反复无常、变化多端），这当然是“男权说教”（mansplaining）的绝对经典。而且墨丘利现在可要惹大麻烦了。是的，他会的。因为事实上，反复无常的那个人是埃涅阿斯。
because he's dumping on his own destiny and he's leading poor Dido astray. So Aeneas bunks off and sails away. And Dido is so upset about this that she piles all the finery for her wedding that she's been gathering together into a great big pile. She stands on top of it, and then she incinerates herself. And she offers herself as a kind of sacrifice to the gods. And as she dies, she swears eternal enmity to the descendants of Aeneas and prophesies that a great scourge will come who will be the great kind of the bane of the Roman people. And that scourge, of course, is Hannibal, the Carthaginian, who will lead the elephants over the Alps and is going to be Rome's greatest enemy. And so poor Dido dies on the funeral pyre.
因为他在抛弃自己的命运，把可怜的狄多引上了歧路。所以埃涅阿斯溜之大吉，扬帆远航。狄多对此感到无比难过，她把一直收集在一起的婚礼盛装堆成了一个大大的柴堆。她站在顶端，然后将自己点燃。她把自己当作一种祭品献给了诸神。在她临死时，她发誓要与埃涅阿斯的后代不共戴天，并预言将有一个大灾星降临，成为罗马人民的巨大克星。而这个灾星，当然就是率领战象翻越阿尔卑斯山的迦太基人汉尼拔，他将成为罗马最大的敌人。于是可怜的狄多在火葬柴堆上死去。
And in due course, Aeneas goes down into the underworld to consult with his father to get kind of various guidance on how to set about fulfilling his destiny. And down there, he meets Dido and Dido refuses to talk to him. So this is the great Roman epic. And since Virgil wrote it, there probably hasn't been a day when people haven't been reading it. It is absolutely the foundational text of European literature. And so Did dido as this great tragic heroine kind of stands at the wellspring of european literature as well as uh you know as as the legendary founder of carthage so the whole thing raises all kinds of interesting i was going to say there's an awful lot to unpack here tom so let me just ask you a couple of questions first of all about the aeneid
随后，埃涅阿斯下到冥界去咨询他的父亲，以获得关于如何履行自己命运的各种指导。在那里，他遇到了狄多，但狄多拒绝和他说话。这就是伟大的罗马史诗。自从维吉尔写下它以来，大概还没有哪一天人们停止阅读它。它绝对是欧洲文学的奠基文本。因此，狄多作为这个伟大的悲剧女主角，不仅站在欧洲文学的发源地上，而且……你知道的，作为迦太基的传奇创立者，整件事引发了各种各样有趣的我本想说，这里有太多内容需要剖析了，汤姆，所以先让我问你几个问题，首先关于《埃涅阿斯纪》
so it's written by virgil and it is written in ways the reign is Augustus emperor so Carthage has been long defeated and long destroyed it has and so Carthage gets destroyed burnt to the ground in 146 BC uh Virgil isn't writing it as history as anything like history it is a it's a celebration of Augustus and his regime and Rome's destiny and, I guess, Roman imperialism, you could say. And Dido, am I right in thinking, so the big enemy for the Romans was Cleopatra. That was who Augustus had beaten to become top dog. So is Dido, is there a bit of Cleopatra in Dido, do you think? I think there absolutely is.
所以它是维吉尔写的，而且它是在奥古斯都皇帝统治时期创作的，所以迦太基早就被击败并摧毁了。确实如此。因此，迦太基在公元前 146 年被摧毁并烧为平地。维吉尔写它并不是为了当作历史，也绝不是什么历史，它是对奥古斯都及其政权、罗马的命运以及我想你可以说是罗马帝国主义的赞歌。至于狄多，我的理解对吗，对罗马人来说最大的敌人是克利奥帕特拉。那是奥古斯都击败以登上巅峰的人。所以狄多，你认为狄多身上有没有克利奥帕特拉的影子？我认为绝对有。
And I think that to appreciate the full radicalism of what Virgil is doing and the Cleopatron spin that he is giving to the legend of Dido, the best thing probably is to look at the alternative sources because there are other traditions. There are other traditions. So there's this guy called Macrobius who's writing a few centuries after Virgil has written the Aeneid. And he says that this tale of Dido, that she died for the passion of Aeneas, is universally acknowledged to be false. So he's saying that Virgil has actually spun this story and presented Dido in an unflattering light. And he says it's universally acknowledged. So that suggests that there is quite another strain of tradition that is running in parallel to what Virgil has written. And if you look at that, there are a kind of number of fragments, of sources, of kind of echoes of traditions that precede Virgil. So Cato the
而且我认为，要体会维吉尔所做事情的彻底激进性，以及他赋予狄多传说的“克利奥帕特拉式”包装，最好的办法大概是去看看替代来源，因为还有其他的传统。还有其他的传统。有个叫马克罗比乌斯（Macrobius）的人，他在维吉尔写完《埃涅阿斯纪》几个世纪后写作。他说，关于狄多因对埃涅阿斯的痴情而死的这个故事，被普遍认为是假的。所以他是说，维吉尔实际上编造了这个故事，并把狄多描绘成了一个不太光彩的形象。他说这是普遍认可的。这表明，还有另一支与维吉尔所写内容平行的传统支流在流传。如果你看看这个，就会发现有许多碎片、来源、对先于维吉尔的传统的呼应。比如老加图（Cato the...
Elder, who is this very stern, strict Roman figure who inspires the Romans to attack Carthage when it's been defeated after Hannibal and end up immolating it, destroying it completely. There's a fragment from a speech that he gives where he says that city, so that is Carthage, was founded by a woman, a Phoenician in origin, so that's all right, called Elissa. So Elissa is an alternative name for Dido. And we might come to why and how that name originated in a few minutes. And then we have a Roman writer living in the third century BC with the splendid name of Trogus. Trogus. Trogus. And basically we have him through a Christian writer who's writing in the third century AD. And he gives the story that Elissa, stroke Dido, is the daughter of the King of Tyre. She has a brother called Akerbis. And he's also a priest of Heracles.
Elder），他是一位非常严厉、严格的罗马人物，他激励罗马人在迦太基在汉尼拔之后被打败并最终被彻底焚毁、彻底摧毁时对其发动进攻。他的一篇演讲中有一个片段，他说那座城市，也就是迦太基，是由一个女人建立的，起源于腓尼基——所以这没问题——名叫埃莉萨（Elissa）。所以埃莉萨是狄多的另一个名字。我们可能在几分钟后讨论这个名字的起源和原因。然后我们还有一位生活在公元前三世纪的罗马作家，他有着一个响亮的名字：特罗古斯（Trogus）。特罗古斯。特罗古斯。基本上我们是通过一位生活在公元三世纪的基督教作家才了解到他的。他讲述了这样一个故事：埃莉萨，也就是狄多，是推罗国王的女儿。她有一个哥哥叫阿凯尔巴斯（Akerbis）。
And he rules while Pygmalion is a young boy. Pygmalion comes of age. And Akerbis is very, very rich. And Pygmalion wants to grab all his gold. And so he has him murdered. And Ido is incredibly upset at this. Yeah. And so she gives orders that all Akerbis' gold should be put into sacks and thrown into the sea as an offering to his shade.
他也是赫拉克勒斯的祭司。在皮格马利翁（Pygmalion）还年轻的时候，由他来统治。皮格马利翁成年了。而阿凯尔巴斯非常非常富有。皮格马利翁想要夺取他所有的黄金。于是他派人谋杀了阿凯尔巴斯。狄多对此感到无比难过。是的。于是她下令将阿凯尔巴斯所有的黄金都装进口袋，扔进海里，作为对他亡灵的祭献。
And then she sails off. And of course, Pygmalion is furious because he thinks he's lost all the gold and silver. No, he's right. But he hasn't. Oh, oh. No, he hasn't. Well, he has.
然后她扬帆出海。当然，皮格马利翁勃然大怒，因为他以为自己失去了所有的金银。不，他是对的。但他并没有。哦，哦。不，他没有。好吧，他确实失去了。
He has. But it hasn't been thrown into the sea because actually those sacks were full of sand oh so what a twist it's alissa who's taken them so she then sails off um she gets to cyprus and there very very groovily she rescues 80 temple prostitutes okay as you do nice that's good so she takes them because she's only got men she's only brought men from tyre so these 80 temple prostitutes will will enable the Carthaginian race to- Be pressed into service.
他失去了。但黄金并没有被扔进海里，因为实际上那些口袋里装的全是沙子。哦，真是个大反转！是埃莉萨把它们拿走了。于是她扬帆起航，嗯，她到达了塞浦路斯，在那里，非常时髦地，她解救了 80 名神庙妓女。好吧，理所当然，这很好。于是她带上了她们，因为她只有男人，她只从推罗带了男人——所以这 80 名神庙妓女将使迦太基种族能够——被征召入伍。
Exactly, exactly. And she wanders off and she wanders and wanders and wanders across the Mediterranean. She comes to Africa and in Africa, they call her Dido, which in the local language means wanderer. So this is how Elissa comes to get the name of Dido. She lands in what will become Tunisia and there she meets the king of the Berbers, a man called Iarbas. And Iarbas says to Dido, you can have as much land as will be contained within an ox hide. And so what Dido does is to cut the ox hide up into very, very, very thin strips.
没错，没错。然后她四处游荡，在整个地中海漫游、漫游、漫游。她来到了非洲，在非洲，当地人叫她狄多，在当地方言里，这个词的意思是“流浪者”。这就是埃莉萨得到“狄多”这个名字的由来。她登陆了日后将成为突尼斯的土地，在那里她遇到了柏柏尔人的国王，一个名叫伊阿尔巴斯（Iarbas）的人。伊阿尔巴斯对狄多说，你可以得到一张牛皮所能包围的土地。于是狄多做的是，把牛皮切成非常、非常、非常细的条。
And then she places it round a hill, which comes to be called Birsa. And in Greek, Birsa is an ox hide. And so this is an illustration of the cunning, the subtlety, the cleverness that will be a leitmotif of the Carthaginians to come. Well, I like that story. I think I may have heard that ox hide story about other people in other places. That's the sort of formula, isn't it? I think this is the classic one. Okay.
然后她把这些牛皮条围在一座小山上，这座小山后来被称为比尔萨（Birsa）。在希腊语中，比尔萨就是牛皮的意思。因此，这展示了日后迦太基人的狡猾、诡秘和聪明的特征。嗯，我喜欢这个故事。我想我可能在其他地方听过关于其他人的这个牛皮故事。这算是一种套路，对吧？我想这是个经典故事。好吧。
This is the kind of the foundational, the definitive story, the canonical story. And in this version, so in the story told by Trogus and in one told by Timaeus, who is a Greek historian from Sicily writing in basically the age of Alexander, it's Iarbus who fancies Dido. And Dido is a very chaste woman. Just to remind people, he's the Berber king. He's the local king. Yes. So he starts going after Dido.
这是那种基础的、决定性的故事，是正统的故事。在这个版本中，也就是在特罗古斯讲述的故事中，以及在蒂迈乌斯（Timaeus）——一位基本上生活在亚历山大大帝时代的西西里希腊历史学家——讲述的故事中，是伊阿尔巴斯看上了狄多。而狄多是一个非常贞洁的女人。提醒大家一下，他是柏柏尔国王。他是当地的国王。是的。所以他开始追求狄多。
And Dido piles, you know, she raises this great pile and immolates herself. But she's doing it to keep the king of the Berbers at bay. So it's, and this is obviously what Macrobius, who's complaining that Virgil has distorted the story, is complaining about. That actually, you know, in Virgil's story, she's dying out of love for this stranger. But in the traditional accounts, she's dying because she's being true to the memory of her murdered husband. So she's a kind of model being true to the memory of her murdered husband so she's a kind of model of wifely chastity and and there's there's a actually the poem written by by a greek a few centuries again after after the Aeneid after Virgil's written it and it has these I never laid
而狄多堆起了，你知道的，她堆起了这个巨大的柴堆并自焚了。但她这么做是为了把柏柏尔国王拒之门外。所以，这显然就是马克罗比乌斯所抱怨的，他抱怨维吉尔扭曲了这个故事。实际上，你知道的，在维吉尔的故事中，她是为了对这个陌生人的爱而死。但在传统记载中，她死是因为她对被谋杀的丈夫的记忆保持着忠诚。所以她某种程度上是忠于被谋杀丈夫记忆的典范。因此，她是一种妻子贞洁的典范，而且事实上，有一首诗是由一个希腊人在《埃涅阿斯纪》以及维吉尔创作它几个世纪之后写成的，其中有这样的诗句：我从未见过。
eyes on Aeneas Dido says I did not come to Libya at the time Troy was sacked Muses why did you equip dread Virgil with weapons against me? So that's her ghost complaining that her memory has been produced. Now, the other question, of course, that hangs over all this is how accurate is it? Well, that's the key question, isn't it? This isn't one of these things that we do and the rest is history that turns out to be utter bunkum, is it? Well, maybe, maybe not. Because what is intriguing about this story is that there are elements within it that are clearly Carthaginian. They are clearly, or perhaps Phoenician. And it's likely that they are drawing on Phoenician or Carthaginian records that were
埃涅阿斯，狄多说，特洛伊沦陷时我并未抵达利比亚。缪斯啊，你们为何为可怕的维吉尔配备了针对我的武器？所以这是她的幽灵在抱怨她的记忆被歪曲了。现在，萦绕这一切的另一个问题是，它有多准确？嗯，这才是关键问题，对吧？这不是我们《历史的余烬》节目中那些最后被证明是彻底胡说八道的事情之一吧？嗯，也许是，也许不是。因为这个故事引人入胜的地方在于，其中有些元素显然带有迦太基的印记。它们显然，或者说可能带有腓尼基的印记。它们很可能是借鉴了腓尼基或迦太基的记录，这些记录在亚历山大大帝时代被一位希腊作家翻译过，也许是一位名叫以弗所的米南德（Menander of Ephesus）的人。
kind of translated in the age of Alexander by a Greek writer, perhaps by a man called Menander of Ephesus. So just to leap in for a second, when do we think Carthage was founded, roughly? That's a hugely open question because Virgil is required to have it founded at the same time as the sack of Troy. But the traditional dates are that it's a little bit later. So it's either kind of the 12th century if you're if you're virgil bc or others say the the 10th the 9th the 8th century it's old i mean it's an old foundation still immensely old and and do we think tom just a one more question so we're on the coast of north
所以打断一下，我们大致认为迦太基是什么时候建立的？这是一个非常开放的问题，因为维吉尔要求它的建立时间与特洛伊陷落同时。但传统日期显示它要稍晚一些。所以如果你是维吉尔，它大约是公元前 12 世纪，或者其他人说是 10 世纪、9 世纪、8 世纪。它很古老，我的意思是它是一个古老的基业，依然极其古老。汤姆，还有一个问题，我们位于北非海岸。
africa the promontory basically that's now tunis um i mean i've been to tunis you can see the remains of what they say is Carthage. So do we think, is it generally felt that it was genuinely was founded by people from what's now Lebanon, from the Phoenicians? So that's absolutely, that is absolutely, yes, it is a Phoenician city. Carthage is the greatest of the many colonies that the Phoenicians found across the Mediterranean. Yes, that is absolutely true. And it is a colony founded by people from Tyre. So that is true. So, and what is even more suggestive is that the names that the Greeks give these characters,
基本上就是现在突尼斯的那个岬角……我的意思是，我去过突尼斯，你可以看到他们所说的迦太基的遗迹。所以我们认为，人们普遍认为它真的是由现在黎巴嫩地区的人、由腓尼基人建立的吗？这是绝对的，绝对是的，它是一座腓尼基城市。迦太基是腓尼基人在整个地中海建立的众多殖民地中最伟大的一座。是的，这绝对是真的。而且它是由来自推罗的人建立的殖民地。所以这是真的。而且，更耐人寻味的是，希腊人给这些角色的名字，
Pygmalion, Elissa, Akirbas, we know what the Phoenician originals would be. So it would be probably Pumiaton is Pygmalion, Elishat is Elissa, Zakabal is Akabas. So these are clearly Greek versions of original Phoenician names. But you mentioned right at the beginning that one of the things for which the Tunisians are famous or were famous is burning children in what were called tophets. So this was something that appalled the Greeks and the Romans, this practice that the Carthaginians and the Phoenicians more generally had. And it is generally accepted
皮格马利翁、埃莉萨、阿凯尔巴斯，我们知道腓尼基语的原名应该是什么。所以皮格马利翁可能应该是普米亚顿（Pymiaton），埃莉萨应该是埃利沙特（Elishat），阿凯尔巴斯应该是扎卡巴尔（Zakabal）。所以这些显然是最初腓尼基名字的希腊语版本。但你在一开始就提到，突尼斯人出名或曾经出名的一件事，就是在被称为托费特（tophet）的地方焚烧儿童。所以，迦太基人和更广泛的腓尼基人这种做法，让希腊人和罗马人感到震惊。现在人们普遍接受这一点，
now because the archaeology seems to back up the tradition that in times of immense stress, the Carthaginians would sacrifice their own children. And to the Greeks and the Romans, this seemed evidence of their kind of monstrous cruelty. But you can frame it in a different way and say that it is actually, they're showing how much they love their children because they're offering to the gods their most precious, their most treasured possessions.
因为考古学似乎支持了传统说法，即在承受巨大压力的时候，迦太基人会献祭自己的亲生骨肉。在希腊人和罗马人看来，这似乎是他们那种残酷无情的证据。但你可以从另一个角度来解读，认为这实际上表明了他们有多么爱自己的孩子，因为他们把最宝贵、最珍重的东西奉献给了神明。
And it's this that gives the whole story of Dido immolating herself. Again, it suggests that it's coming from a Carthaginian tradition. So Trogus in his account says that the pyre is on the edge of Carthage. And archaeology has shown that the Tophet, the place where these immolations happened, was indeed on the southern edge of the town. And although the tradition
正是这一点构成了狄多自焚整个故事的基础。同样，这也表明它源自迦太基的传统。因此，特罗古斯在叙述中说，火葬柴堆位于迦太基的边缘。而考古学表明，托费特，即这些献祭发生的地方，确实位于城镇的南部边缘。尽管传统暗示
implies that it's children, it's not only children. So right at the end of Carthage in 146, when the Romans storm, they capture the city, they're going to absolutely destroy it, level it to the ground, leave it as a cursed site. The wife of the defeated Carthaginian commander, Hasdrubal, she is in a temple. And as the flames lick at the tower, she hurls herself into the flames, herself and all her children. So she's consciously immolating herself in a way to try and win the favor of the gods. And is she doing that, do you think, because she's conscious of the myth of Dido and she wants to kind of, that's a model for her? Or do you think that's not right?
牺牲的都是儿童，但并非只有儿童。所以在公元前 146 年迦太基灭亡的最后时刻，当罗马人突袭并攻占这座城时，他们打算彻底摧毁它，将其夷为平地，使其成为一片受诅咒的废墟。被击败的迦太基指挥官哈斯杜鲁巴尔（Hasdrubal）的妻子当时正身处一座神庙中。当烈焰舔舐着塔楼时，她将自己投入了烈火之中，带着她所有的孩子一起。所以她是有意识地自焚，以此来试图赢得神明的青睐。你认为她这么做，是因为她意识到了狄多的神话，并想把这当作自己的榜样吗？还是你觉得并非如此？
That may well be it. That may well be it. Or it may well be that she is part of a continuum that reaches back to Dido, that the story of Dido has kind of originated to explain why this is a tradition among the Carthaginians. We don't know. But what it does suggest is that the origins of this story that get taken up by Virgil do indeed lie in Carthaginian tradition. And I think that there are other elements as well within the Carthaginian tradition that suggests that there may well be something to this. So it's very important to the Carthaginians that they're not assimilated into the native African population. So the story of Dido killing herself rather than allowing herself to be married to the King of the Berbers, that may well be a kind of originating story designed to justify
很有可能是这样。很有可能就是这样。或者，她可能是一条一直延伸到狄多的历史长河的一部分，狄多故事的起源可能就是为了解释为什么这是迦太基人的一项传统。我们不得而知。但它确实表明，被维吉尔采纳的这个故事的起源确实植根于迦太基的传统。而且我认为迦太基传统中还有其他元素也表明，这个故事可能确实有其真实基础。因此，对于迦太基人来说，非常重要的一点是，他们没有被当地的非洲人口同化。所以狄多宁死也不愿嫁给柏柏尔国王的故事，很可能是为了证明
this kind of Carthaginian hands-off approach. And isn't it interesting that they're not the only people in North Africa to have done that? Because in previous podcasts, Tom, when we talked about the Ptolemies and Cleopatra, I mean, they were Macedonian Greeks who, again, didn't marry into the local population. Keeping their bloodline pure was very important to them. And here we've got an older dynasty, I suppose, more than a dynasty, a settlement where they don't intermarry with the local Berber tribes at all. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, and so the relationship of Alexandria to Egypt and the relationship of Carthage to the African hinterland is very similar. These remain naval powers looking out to the sea rather than inland and determined to preserve a sense of their identity. And perhaps
这种迦太基人与当地保持距离的做法是合理的，而这或许就是一个起源故事。有趣的是，他们并不是北非唯一这样做的人，对吧？因为在之前的播客中，汤姆，当我们谈到托勒密王朝和克利奥帕特拉时，他们是马其顿希腊人，同样也没有与当地人口通婚。保持血统纯洁对他们来说非常重要。而在这里，我们有一个更古老的王朝，或者说与其说是王朝，不如说是一个定居点，他们根本不与当地的柏柏尔部落通婚。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，亚历山大里亚与埃及的关系，以及迦太基与非洲腹地的关系非常相似。这些依然是面向大海而非内陆的海权国家，决心维护他们的身份认同。或许
the only clue we have, material clue we have to Dido's identity or the sense that the Carthaginians had of her as their foundress is that there were coins minted by the Carthaginians that have been found in Italy in the fourth century BC. And they show a woman, very stylish looking woman, wearing a kind of Phrygian, so a kind of Asian tiara. No name, but it was the custom for Greek cities to put the image of their founder. And so it may well have been the same for the Carthaginians. So it may be that the head of this woman is meant to represent Elissa. Well, so you put all this together, and I think you can see that there's a really fascinating swirl there in which the figure of Dido could be cast by the Romans
我们所拥有的关于狄多身份的唯一线索，或者说迦太基人对她作为建立者印象的唯一物质线索，是公元前四世纪在意大利发现了迦太基人铸造的硬币。它们上面刻着一个女人，一个看起来非常时髦的女人，戴着一种弗里吉亚式的、也就是某种亚洲式的头饰。没有名字，但希腊城市习惯于把他们奠基人的形象铸在上面。因此迦太基人很可能也是如此。所以这个女人的头像可能代表的是埃莉萨。好吧，所以把这一切结合起来，我想你可以看到，其中存在着一个非常迷人的旋涡，在这个旋涡中，狄多可以被罗马人塑造成
as a representative of Carthage, and therefore very much a kind of villainous figure. Savage, cruel, treacherous. This is the image that the Romans have of the Carthaginians. But what's fascinating about what Virgil is doing is actually, despite what Macrobius is saying, that you've produced the name of Dido, actually what he's doing is casting Dido and the Carthaginians as rather Roman, really. The city that they're founding is very like Rome. So Tom, let's just take a break here because in good Roman style,
迦太基的代表，因此在很大程度上是一个反派形象。野蛮、残酷、奸诈。这就是罗马人对迦太基人的印象。但维吉尔的做法最迷人的地方在于，尽管马克罗比乌斯说你编造了狄多的名字，但实际上他的做法是将狄多和迦太基人塑造得相当具有罗马色彩。他们建立的这座城市非常像罗马。所以汤姆，让我们在这里休息一下，因为按照标准的罗马风格，
we're all about the commerce. So that's more Carthaginian, I think. Is it more? Yeah, I suppose Phoenician entrepreneurs. Trading city. Right. Well, let's allow a bit of trading to take place and then reconvene.
我们一切以商业为主。所以这更具有迦太基风格，我想。是这样吗？是的，我想大概是腓尼基式的企业家。贸易之城。好吧，让我们进行一点贸易，然后再重新集合。
You keep that thread in mind. We'll reconvene post-trading and you can tell us about what appears to be the transformation of Dido in the Roman imagination. So we'll see you in a minute for more Tunisian-based podcasting. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
你把这条线索记在心里。我们会在贸易结束后重新集合，你可以跟我们讲讲狄多在罗马人想象中似乎发生的转变。我们一会儿见，继续收听突尼斯主题的播客。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking today about Tunisia, one of the North African competitors in the World Cup. And Tom has chosen to focus on the story of Dido, the legendary queen of Carthage. Probably, I mean, one of the two or three single most well-known,
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。如果你想要无广告音频、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的资格，我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们今天的主义是突尼斯，世界杯北非参赛国之一。汤姆选择聚焦于迦太基传奇女王狄多的故事。可能，我的意思是，从突尼斯走出来的人当中，最广为人知、
most sort of culturally important people to come out of Tunisia, I would say, wouldn't you, Tom? I mean, obviously, Tunisia itself is a later creation, but to come out of that part of the world. Yeah. So Carthage is a great rival to Rome for the control of the Western Mediterranean. And it's the defeat of Carthage that enables Rome basically to rule as mistress of the whole, not just the Western Mediterranean, but the whole Mediterranean. So the conflict with Carthage is the great foundational story for Rome. And so that's why Virgil chooses to center it, I think. And you were just saying before the break,
在文化上最重要的两三个人物之一，我想你会这么认为吧，汤姆？我的意思是，显然突尼斯本身是一个后来的产物，但我是指来自那个世界的人。是的。所以迦太基是罗马争夺西地中海控制权的强大对手。正是对迦太基的击败，使罗马得以成为不仅是西地中海、而且是整个地中海的女主人。因此，与迦太基的冲突是罗马伟大的奠基故事。我认为这就是为什么维吉尔选择以它为中心。就像你在休息之前刚刚说的那样，
before I rudely interrupted you to do some Phoenician-style trading, that you were saying that Virgil had changed Dido's image. So she'd become almost this idea of the sort of founding of the city and a Rome-style myth. So what's going on there? Because she's not a villain in the need, and you'd think she would be. Well, it's very, very interesting. So Ineos turns up, and Dido is very welcoming, and she provides tremendous hospitality. And Virgil gives a description of the building of Carthage that makes it sound very much like an kind of, you know, an exemplary Roman city. And I think that what then changes is that Aeneas is told to go off
在我粗鲁地打断你进行腓尼基式贸易之前，你曾说维吉尔改变了狄多的形象。所以她几乎变成了城市建立的理念和罗马式神话的一部分。这其中到底是怎么回事？因为她在《埃涅阿斯纪》中并不是一个反派，而你本以为她会是的。嗯，这非常非常有趣。所以埃涅阿斯出现了，狄多非常热情，她提供了极大的盛情款待。维吉尔对迦太基建设的描述，让它听起来非常像一个，你知道的，模范的罗马城市。而我认为接下来发生变化的是，埃涅阿斯被告知要离开，
and he sails away. And it's then that Dido's character starts to darken. So she's so upset that she kind of contemplates cutting up Aeneas into little pieces and scattering the body parts into the sea, rather like Medea does with her brother in the Legend of the Golden Fleece. And she thinks about burning the Trojans in their ships, all this kind of stuff. But then, of course, she doesn't do any of this. And instead, what she does is she immolates herself and she calls vengeance down on the descendants of Aeneas as she dies. And so I think that what Virgil is doing is saying that although Aeneas is being obedient
于是他扬帆起航。正是在那时，狄多的性格开始变黑。她非常难过，甚至考虑把埃涅阿斯切成小块，把尸体碎片扔进海里，就像美狄亚在《金羊毛》的传说中对待她的兄弟那样。她甚至考虑把特洛伊人的船只付之一炬，诸如此类的事情。但当然，她并没有这么做。相反，她做的是自焚，并在临死前召唤对埃涅阿斯后代的复仇。所以我想维吉尔的意思是，尽管埃涅阿斯在服从
to his destiny, he has to do what he has to do. Nevertheless, it does come with costs. And one of those costs is the creation of the kind of malevolent, dark city that Carthage becomes. That in a sense, Aeneas' sense of piety, he's pious Aeneas. It's not exactly pious, he's kind of dutiful. He's respectful of the charge laid on him by the gods. He has to stick to that. But it's that that makes Carthage what it is as well, and sets in train this kind of great cycle of wars that will, in the long run, enable Rome to emerge as the mistress of the world. But it comes at cost.
他的命运，他必须做他必须做的事。然而，这确实付出了代价。其中一个代价就是催生了迦太基后来成为的那座充满恶意、黑暗的城市。在某种意义上，埃涅阿斯的虔诚感——他是虔诚的埃涅阿斯。这不完全是虔诚，他是一种尽责。他尊重诸神赋予他的使命。他必须坚持这一点。但正是这一点造就了今天的迦太基，并引发了这场漫长的战争循环，从长远来看，这将使罗马成为世界的女主。但这付出了代价。
And that, I think, is the mirror that is also being held up to Antony and Cleopatra, because there are obvious parallels there. So Antony is a great Roman hero, but he has been seduced, according to the Virgilian perspective, the Augustan perspective, by the wiles and the seductions of Cleopatra. And so that is an obvious kind of echo. But I think that the Aeneid is a great poem. It's a powerful poem. It's a moving poem. It's a complex poem, because Virgil is not just writing Augustan propaganda and he's not even writing just Roman propaganda. He's acknowledging the costs of empire. He's acknowledging the costs of duty and responsibility. And it's that that
而且我认为，这也是一面映射安东尼和克利奥帕特拉的镜子，因为其中有明显的相似之处。所以安东尼是一位伟大的罗马英雄，但根据维吉尔的视角、奥古斯都的视角，他被克利奥帕特拉的诡计和诱惑所蛊惑。所以这是一个明显的呼应。但我认为《埃涅阿斯纪》是一首伟大的诗。它是一首充满力量的诗。它是一首感人的诗。它是一首复杂的诗，因为维吉尔写的不只是奥古斯都的宣传，他甚至不只是在写罗马的宣传。他承认了帝国的代价。他承认了责任与义务的代价。正是这一点，
makes the story of Dido, I think, properly tragic. Because it gives it an ambiguity, I suppose. Yeah. And it becomes the tragedy of carthage as well as of of dido but um but dominic i'm very glad that you um that you asked about the parallel between dido and this is always this is always ominous when you say you're glad about that i've asked something yes because it provides me a scope for some for some self-promotion so i may have mentioned that i wrote an opera about geopatra yeah in which all the um all the arias so it's a kind of the mamma mia of of opera um all the arias come from 19th century um come from the 19th century but we when dido dies there's the
我认为才让狄多的故事真正具有悲剧色彩。因为这赋予了它一种模糊性，我想。是的。这也成为了迦太基的悲剧，同时也是狄多的悲剧。不过，多米尼克，我很高兴你……你问到了狄多和……这总是，当你这么说时总是很不祥，我问了什么问题吗？是的，因为这给我提供了一个自我宣传的空间。我可能提过我写了一部关于克利奥帕特拉的歌剧。是的，里面所有的咏叹调——所以这有点像歌剧界的《妈妈咪呀》——所有的咏叹调都来自19世纪。都来自19世纪。但当狄多死去时，有那首著名的哀歌，珀塞尔的歌剧《狄多与埃涅阿斯》里的。是的，非常、非常著名。我只是稍微调整了一下，因为那是用英文写的，不像我们使用的所有其他咏叹调。我稍微调整了一下，让它适合由克利奥帕特拉而不是狄多来演唱。我和两个朋友詹姆斯·摩根（James Morgan）和朱丽叶·波钦（Juliet Pochin）一起完成了这件事。朱丽叶本身就是个歌手。她非常友好地演唱了这首咏叹调。哦，所以你不会唱。真让人失望。我不会唱，因为朱丽叶是伟大的歌手。所以朱丽叶非常友善地同意演唱克利奥帕特拉的哀歌。
famous lament purcell's opera dido and anias yeah we're Very, very famous. And I just very, very slightly tweaked it because that's written in English, unlike all the other arias we use. I very, very slightly tweaked it to make it appropriate for Cleopatra to sing rather than Dido. I did it with two friends, James Morgan and Juliet Pochin. And Juliet was a singer herself. And she's very kindly sung the aria. Oh, so you're not going to sing. That is disappointing. I'm not going to because Juliet is the great singer. So Juliet has very kindly agreed to sing Cleopatra's Lament.
这是由我重新改编的狄多哀歌。那么，朱丽叶，请开始吧。愿我的爱不再带来麻烦，我已长眠地下。不再有麻烦，我心中不再有麻烦。记住我，因为你就是我的命运。记住我，你是我的朋友。记住我。记住我，你就是我的信仰。记住我。
It's Dido's Lament reworked by me. And so, Julietiet take it away May my love create no trouble, am laid in earth, No trouble, no trouble in my breast. Remember me For you are my fate Remember me You are my friend Remember me Remember me You are my faith Remember me
你就是我的信仰。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想要独家加更、抢先收听、无广告音频以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取
You are my faith. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的资格，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加入我们的会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告节目、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。